another georgia county uncovers votes
while trump fires his homeland security
cyber chief who claimed the election is
secure
facebook and twitter get grilled by
congress again and georgia's democratic
senate candidate rafael warnock gets
vetted i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
stop putting your online data at risk
get protected at expressvpn.com we'll
get to all the news
in just one moment first if this holiday
season feels like it's been a long time
coming make it worth the wait with omaha
steaks the greatest of all gifts so
got a year back i'm hustling got me like
kosher steak and let me tell you
they do stay great i'm a big steak
aficionado i love burgers i love steaks
i love
the meat and omaha steaks i mean this
stuff is so juicy it is so good
it is so tasty i mean they age their
meat perfectly omaha steaks are aged at
least
21 days their omaha steaks private
reservation at least 28 days
their dry aged beef program stretches
their time all the way out to a full 60
days so i mean they really know how to
age thick and that means it's just as
juicy
and tasty as you could possibly imagine
they've got these caramel apple tartlets
that are apparently my staff has tried
them they're apparently crunchy and also
delicious
they have the burgers which are
basically like grilled steaks because
they put
the right seasoning on it i mean this is
all just amazing stuff if your mouth is
starting to water just listening to this
that's how i feel every time i think
about it this is why you should go check
out
omaha steaks right now right now you get
a mouth watering package plus four free
burgers and a free digital meat
thermometer at an exclusive price
available only
to my listeners this is deluxe griller's
assortment it includes a vast variety of
entrees
sides desserts you get a discount of
over 50 go to omahasteaks.com
enter the code shapiro into the search
bar again go to omahastakes.com enter
the code shapiro
into the search bar omaha steaks isn't
just steak it is a guaranteed fantastic
gift
a safe way to share the joy of the
season don't forget when you order that
deluxe griller's assortment you also get
free
for free omaha steaks burgers and a free
digital meat thermometer with my code
shapiro at omahasteaks.com it's a deal
you will not find
anywhere else they deliver guaranteed
quality and safety with every order
visit omahastakes.com type shapiro in
that search bar to shop for the best
gourmet gifts of the season i mean
imagine how happy you or a family member
is going to be when they receive the
greatest available gift
i mean that's pretty awesome stuff this
holiday season omahasteaks.com and use
that promo code shapiro in the search
bar at the top to get the special gift
okay so
we continue to follow the outcome of the
2020 election
and chaos continues to dominate the
process there's
some good news for team trump there's
some bad news for team trump
just for clarification on all this we've
asked sidney powell on the show we'll
see if sydney powell who is the
trump team lawyer to if she comes on the
show she of course has suggested that
the kraken will be released and my
suggestion is
do it now like what exactly are we
waiting for if you have
a kraken in the waiting if you have an
enormous amount of information
suggesting widespread voter fraud or
voter irregularity that would switch the
outcome
of an american presidential election
like you know it'd be a great time to
release all that information
yesterday you know what also be a great
time today you know it'd be a terrible
time
tomorrow because all of these states are
beginning to certify
their election results so yesterday
another georgia county has uncovered 2
700 missing votes this makes the second
georgia county
that has now uncovered thousands of
missing votes which obviously is a
terrible look
according to wsb tv the georgia
secretary of state's office says another
county
has found missing votes during their
audit of the ballots in the presidential
race this comes as secretary of state
brad
raffensberger has started firing back
after more than a week of criticism from
president trump
raffensburger says it was the
president's own attacks on absentee
ballots that cost him the election in
georgia
so his suggestion is that because trump
kept saying mail and ballots are a bad
thing
a lot of republicans didn't use the mail
inbounds but that's election analysis
which we don't need from him
what we actually need from him is a safe
and secure election so who cares about
his opinions
on mail-in ballots or why trump
supposedly lost how about we get from
him
you know a verified vote count in which
thousands of votes are not ignored
raffensberger said he actually
suppressed depressed his own voting base
now raffensburg is a republican i
understand he's trying to cover his butt
here a little bit but it's not a great
look when you have
5 400 votes that suddenly magically
appear during an audit
the secretary of state said some 24 500
georgia republicans who voted absentee
in the june primary did not actually
vote in the
general election during the hand recount
on tuesday fayette county uncovered
2755 votes that were not included in the
initial account secretary of state
official gabriel sterling said those
ballots were scanned onto a card but the
votes were never uploaded into the
initial account
he says there were several backups
designed to catch this issue and that it
falls to workers who didn't follow
procedure of the votes that are now
being added to the total 1577 were for
trump 1128 were for biden the rest were
for joe jorgensen or write-ins which
changes the margin in the state by 500
votes
biden now leads trump by about 12 929
votes that margin is down about a
thousand votes just from those two
counties alone
okay this that does show an awful lot of
election error it really does i mean
when we had the recounts the hand
recounts in florida it shifted the
voting total by a couple hundred votes
not a thousand votes
fayette is the second county to report
an issue with missing votes on monday
floyd county uncovered 2 600 votes that
were missed during the initial count on
election night the secretary of state's
office said it was human error
and called for the elections director in
the county to step down
those votes changed the margin by about
800 in favor of president trump
the margin was similar in the purdue
assaf race that would be david perdue
and john ossoff will not affect the
runoff according to secretary of state
official
gabriel sterling the guardrails that
were there caught this we're going to be
able to put those results in the final
amount sterling also said they're
investigating a potential memory card
with 224 votes on it in walton county
that may have been missed the secretary
of state's office also opened
two investigations in fulton county the
first into how a water leak at state
farm arena was handled the second is how
elections monitors
were handled of the other counties that
have completed their recounts
57 had no deviations from the original
ballot count 21 counties were either
plus or minus one
off of the original ballot count 32
counties are off by single-digit numbers
and are being investigated so it is not
as though these are coming in one by one
or a high percentage of the counties
are reporting extra votes that have not
yet been found but obviously when you
find giant caches of votes when you find
2700 votes 2 400 votes that have not
been counted
that is not a good thing and is going to
plant in people's minds the idea
that at least some screw-ups took place
right here
meanwhile president trump has filed new
lawsuits in nevada
the trump campaign late last night said
it was challenging nevada's election
results under a state law that lets
candidates contest an election based on
allegedly fraudulent votes and other
grounds
according to the washington post in a
document filed on tuesday republicans
asked a state court in carson city to
declare trump the winner of nevada's six
presidential electors
or to annul the election entirely
meaning no winner would be certified
from nevada
the document promises evidence of fraud
but does not provide it okay if you're
gonna
seriously like this is not this sort of
move you need real evidence for if
you're going to disenfranchise
the millions of voters in a state like
nevada then you actually are going to
have to show the election fraud you
don't get to say there's the possibility
of election fraud so we are going to
throw out all the votes in the entire
state you actually have to show
widespread voter fraud
because as much of a fan of
republican rather than democratic ideals
as i am meaning small republican meaning
checks and balances on mob rule
okay people's votes count this is a
democracy still
it is a democratic republic okay what
that means is that you can't just
disenfranchise an entire state's votes
based on mere allegations you need
actual evidence now if there's actual
evidence
that a hundred thousand votes or ten
thousand votes that would shift the
election outcome
are are being uh voter fraud is found
voter regularity is found that shifts
the outcome
so you disenfranchise the entire state's
vote well
then i guess that's what you do but you
actually have to show evidence that that
is the case
you don't just get to file to invalidate
state counts all over the place if the
state counts don't go your way
and that that's that's bad for the
country it's a bad strategy
again show the evidence i'm a big
evidence guy you show me the evidence
i'm good right you showed me the
evidence in georgia that
the 5 400 votes 5100 votes were found
outstanding
excellent this is evidence this is
evidence that votes were missing
but if the if the evidence is there's
the possibility of voter fraud
that ain't going to cut it to
disenfranchise an entire state like
nevada for example
the election contest filed filed tuesday
reprises some of the previously rejected
allegations rejected
by the state of nevada by the courts
including the claim that clark county
officials violated state law by using a
machine to verify some mail-in
signatures
rather than processing them all manually
other claims include that officials did
not allow for meaningful
observation that people voted improperly
in the state and that some people were
offered improper incentives to vote
under nevada law parties to the case may
take depositions of any witnesses the
court must hold
a hearing in five to ten days clark
county registrar gloria has said his
staff has forwarded isolated complaints
about alleged voter fraud to the
secretary of state
for further investigation overall he
says he's confident in the county's
election system
nevada democratic party chairman william
mccurdy said the challenges alleging
fraud and clark county should be
regarded as attempts to discredit the
electoral process well that's too strong
okay how about this how about they have
distraught evidence if they don't show
evidence
then that's not a good thing they have
to show evidence the nevada secretary of
state's office has not commented
that process will be moving forward
meanwhile we'll get to pennsylvania in
just one second
plus we have to get to michigan which
became a hot spot of contention
last night first let's talk about the
fact that the human eye not meant to
look at
blues blue light from screens all day
it's just not
in fact when the human eye was created
by god or by evolution or both
well it turns out that the eye was not
made to look at screens right screens
did not exist we created them for
ourselves well that means that
artificial blue light can
really screw with your sleep quality it
can give you headaches this is why you
need felix gray
felix gray makes eyewear for everywhere
modern lenses to help manage our digital
lives felix gray glasses filter 15 times
more blue light from screens than other
clear
blue light lenses the original optical
lenses relieve most eye strain symptoms
from daily screen time
the more advanced sleep glasses relieve
serious daily eye strain and were
especially designed for late night
screen time
to improve sleep felix gray features
highly curated timeless styles made from
italian acetate for stylish durable
lightweight super comfortable glass i
know because i have these glasses
industry leading blue light lenses comes
standard at 95 bucks or you can add a
prescription at checkout starting at 145
bucks
okay this is not going to cost you a
fortune and it's going to save your eyes
it's going to save you from headaches
it's gonna make you sleep better join
the 250
000 people that report noticeable relief
from screen time with their glasses if
you don't love those glasses
in the first 30 days their in-house
customer care team will take care of
exchanges and returns as well shop 15
off through black friday and cyber
monday go to felixgrayglasses.com to
shop
better blue light glasses at their best
price ever that is f-e-l-i-x-g-r-a-y
glasses dot com slash ben felix grey
glasses dot com slash ben
for 15 off site-wide through black
friday cyber monday free shipping
free returns free exchanges felix
grayglasses.com and go check them out
right now okay so meanwhile in
pennsylvania the pennsylvania supreme
court threw out one of the trump
campaign's
post-election complaints tuesday is
according to nbc news ruling that
officials in philadelphia did not
violate state law
by maintaining at least 15 feet of
separation between observers and the
workers
counting the ballots okay so that was
one of the claims that had been made is
that it had not
amounted to effective observation if you
were forced to stand 15 feet back thanks
to coveted regulations the pennsylvania
supreme court says if it applies to
everybody then it is not in fact
an equal protection concern right it's
not you're saying to republicans you
have to stand 20 feet back and democrats
can be one foot up
on the person now this was an equally
applied rule and the truly applied rule
is what the pennsylvania supreme court
says
the ruling is likely to undercut the
trump campaign's case in federal court
where rudy giuliani joined a hearing on
tuesday afternoon
to argue on behalf of president trump's
effort to contest the election results
in pennsylvania republican observers
said they were kept so far back behind a
waste high fence they couldn't see any
of the details on ballot envelopes or
reach conclusions about whether vote
counting procedures were correctly
followed the trump campaign sued a state
appeals court said observers were not
given enough access
it ordered the county to move the funds
closer to the counting tables the state
supreme court reversed that ruling by a
vote of five to two
it said that pennsylvania law requires
only that observers must be allowed in
the room where ballots are counted but
does not set a minimum distance between
them
and the counting table the legislature
left it up to county election boards to
make these decisions
according to the court in the case of
philadelphia the local board quote
fashioned these rules based on its
careful consideration
of how it could best protect the
security and privacy of voter ballots as
well as safeguard its employees and
others
would be present during the pandemic
republican observer jeremy mercer
testified during lower court proceedings
he could see employees removing ballots
from the security envelopes but could
not read any markings in the outer
envelopes
tuesday's ruling said state law does not
allow observers to make challenges while
votes are being
counted okay so that is a dicey ruling
it definitely is i mean if the
legislature
says that you have to be able to observe
and then philadelphia is like you know
what if i observe
we are going to put you at one end of
this hockey arena
and you're in the same room so that's
okay you can be there with binoculars
and we'll be all the way over here
counting the votes that obviously
is no good now a similar case has been
filed in federal court under equal
protection claims
we'll see how well that does chief
justice thomas saylor
dissented writing that he would have
declared the case mood given the
accounting is nearly done
and he said the state legislature is
signaling there will be an intense
after-action review of the no excuse
mainland voting regime he also said it
was misguided to argue that
presumptively
valid ballots cast by the pennsylvania
electorate would be disregarded based on
isolated
procedural irregularities so the trump
campaign was looking for a remedy
in the entire pennsylvania state vote
not being certified
okay now again you have to prove more
than my guys were a little far away
in order to invalidate the state count
of a state like pennsylvania which is an
enormous state with a lot a lot of
people who voted
meanwhile giuliani appeared in court
this is the first time that giuliani has
appeared as a registered lawyer in court
since apparently 1992
when i was eight years old uh which
shows that the the trump team
uh is um is desperate for legal help at
this point i mean just to be perfectly
frank about this
rudy uh is it was a very good mayor of
new york i'm not sure that he would be
your first legal pick
rudy was representing the trump campaign
at a hearing on a lawsuit he said
observers in philadelphia were kept at
bay by quote-unquote the democratic
machine
he said it was part of quote widespread
nationwide voter fraud
okay this resulted in both the judge and
the opposing counsel
chiding rudy giuliani according to the
new york daily news
so giuliani appeared and he said that
the he said that the democratic mafia
had essentially stolen the election by
shifting more than one million illegal
votes to joe biden
apparently he didn't talk much about the
legal case he said the best description
of this situation is widespread
nationwide voter fraud
this is not an isolated case this is a
case that is repeated in at least 10
other
jurisdictions giuliani said the point is
your honor this is not an accident
you have to be a fool to think this was
an accident
he said that democratic officials in
pennsylvania saw to it that only their
quote unquote little mafia were allowed
to count ballots in the november third
election and that roughly 1.5 million
votes should be invalidated as a result
now it is worth noting here that
trump actually overperformed in
philadelphia compared to 2016. it is one
of the few cities where trump
actually did better in 2020 than he did
in 2016. a lot of the other cities he
did not in philadelphia he actually did
by the vote count daniel donovan an
attorney appearing on behalf of
pennsylvania secretary of state kathy
buchvar the lead defendant in the case
pointed out the trump campaign's lawsuit
didn't even include allegations of fraud
so why exactly was giuliani talking
about it that's correct the the trump
team
did remove allegations of voter fraud
from
their original filing in this case
instead they were arguing basically that
ballots
that were being counted without a
postmark after the election date
should not be counted the problem there
is there aren't enough of those ballots
to actually shift
the direction of the election in
pennsylvania given that the current vote
tabulation
has joe by joe biden up by about 70 000
votes in
pennsylvania the judge signaled he was
not super impressed he said how can this
result possibly be justified
suggesting this would be giuliani's
claim that millions of pennsylvania
voters should have their ballots tossed
and then giuliani said this isn't a
fraud case and he said the trump
campaign only wants illegal ballots
scratched so it's kind of a mess we'll
see where all of that
comes out meanwhile there was another uh
moment of of uncertainty and chaos last
night
in michigan's wayne county so apparently
two republicans on michigan's wayne
county board of canvassers
was involved they were involved in a
brief deadlock in the county's election
certification process
so they were given the deadline of late
last night to actually certify the
election result from wayne county wayne
county of course
includes detroit okay and the board of
canvassers is split two two
it is a partisan office and there are
two democrats and two republicans on the
board of canvassers
two of the republicans voted originally
to not certify
the election result from wayne county
based on allegations of voter fraud and
voter irregularities
now the evidence of voter fraud and
voter regularities definitely exist in
william county
the question is whether again it is of
the size and scope
to actually change the outcome of the
election number one
and number two you know compared to the
generalized voting population how large
is it
uh you're always going to be able to
find cases of voter regularity and voter
fraud you are just
any sample size if it's large enough is
going to include flawed samples
it is going to include vote this is why
when you see the media and democrats
saying there is no such thing as voter
fraud there are no voter irregularities
that's just crazy obviously there are
instances of voter fraud they're
instances of voter irregularities
typically they do not amount to the tens
of thousands let alone the hundreds of
thousands
but they obviously exist well last night
the wayne county
board of canvassers split 2-2 on
certifying the election then a couple
hours later they reversed themselves
they sided with the democratic
colleagues and they leveraged from the
michigan secretary of state
a a commitment to audit the vote right
in the same way that george is currently
auditing the vote which of course is the
proper solution you want to audit the
vote you want to get all the votes
checked you want to make sure that they
all came in the right way
now is that going to reverse the result
in michigan probably not i mean
joe biden is about 150 000 votes in
michigan that's a huge gap
that is not a gap that's going to be
filled by wayne county it's not a gap
that's going to be filled by by voter
fraud or voter regularity absent again
some sort of systemic
exposed cis system of corruption
that that is brought to light barring
sydney power actually releasing the
kraken that apparently is being hidden
barring that happening the vote in
michigan is probably not going to shift
and so the legal strategy here
apparently is that the entire state of
michigan should not certify as voters
something that's not going to happen
again nor barring extraordinary evidence
with extraordinary evidence sure
right if there's if there is real
evidence of significant widespread voter
fraud amounting to tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands of votes
then of course you're going to have to
disregard an election this has happened
in other elections in smaller scale
we had this happen in a case in north
carolina for example where ballot
harvesting
by a hired hand of apparently a
republican campaign led to election
uncertainty and they read the vote
okay you could have something like that
but the evidence has to actually be
there
right you actually have to show the
evidence i keep i get a lot of flack for
saying i want to see evidence but again
my standards on this stuff are very very
consistent i want evidence across the
board on everything from police shooting
cases to voter fraud
you have to actually support your
allegations
with evidence okay kaylee mcinerney
announced earlier on twitter there were
234 pages of sworn affidavits that
raised allegations of fraud
in wayne county and the blazes leon wolf
did go through those allegations what he
found
is that under a thousand votes were
actually affected by those voter
allegations a lot of those voter
allegations
were things like people were being mean
to me at the balloting places which is
bad
and not good practice but is not enough
to actually invalidate the votes of
presumably over a million people in
wayne county
there are a bunch of um there are a
bunch of
republicans who came out and praised the
two canvassers who are republicans on
the board
um which again if they held this thing
up just that they can get an audit then
really they do deserve applause right i
mean if they said
we are going to not certify this
election until we get a commitment from
the state to audit the election
good for them john james the republican
senate candidate from the state
who's black he applauded them for their
bravery laura cox the michigan
republican party's chairwoman
also said in a statement there appeared
to be enough evidence of irregularity
and potential voter fraud
to to affect all of this
and then president trump tweeted wow
michigan just refused to certify the
election results having courage is a
beautiful thing the usa stands proud
well that's not actually what happened
right basically the michigan board of
canvassers held up for a couple
hours uh the michigan vote certification
so that they could get a commitment to
actually audit the vote and ensure that
everything is being done on the up and
up then they obviously reversed
themselves
and went ahead and voted with the
democrats in order to in order to move
forward with the certification
of the election in wayne county so that
is the latest we'll bring you
more on that in just one moment
first let's talk about a truly
meaningful gift so over my mantle in my
home
hangs a picture that picture is a
portrait it's a beautiful portrait of me
and my wife and two of our three
children well now it's time for us to
re-up
where are we gonna go to get that
portrait re-up a new portrait with my
little tiny squishy baby we are going to
go
over to paint your life because that's
where we went in the first place it's
just fantastic you can get a
professional
hand-painted portrait created from any
photo at a truly affordable price this
makes a fantastic holiday
gift particular for mom and dad you can
send any picture yourself your kids
family a special place a cherished pet
or you can combine photos into one
painting with paint your life's
compilation portraits you can bring
together family members who never had
the chance to meet
or you can create a portrait of the
whole family without the need for
everyone to be there for a family photo
they can choose from a team of
world-class artists and work with them
until every detail is perfect
you can order a custom-made hand-painted
portrait in less than five minutes it's
a quick and easy process
you get a hand-painted portrait in about
three weeks it's meaningful it's
personal it can be cherished forever
it's beautiful i mean again we have it
like right dead center in our den at
paintyourlife.com
there is no risk if you don't love the
final painting your money is refunded
go check them out right now and get a
special offer text the word ben
to 64 again text the word ben
to sixty four thousand and as limited
time offer you get twenty percent off
your painting
twenty percent off and free shipping
text the word ben to sixty four thousand
to get started
with my friends over at paint your life
okay so
again the wayne county board of
canvassers they kind of switched their
mind last night they changed course
tuesday night they did certify the
results
of the election that deadlocked decision
had been lauded by republicans and
decried by democrats after a lengthy
public comment session
the vote was described as a targeted
attack on detroit of course after hours
of angry responses from wayne county
residents
the change in course was approved by two
republicans and the two democrats with
the demand that the secretary of state's
office conduct a comprehensive audit of
precincts with unexplained
out-of-balance tallies so my
understanding of of balance tallies is
that people filed
for absentee ballots and then the number
of absentee ballots that came in did not
match the number of absentee ballots
that were in fact
requested so they want an audit to make
sure that that is uh that all of that is
legit
uh apparently the republicans listened
to the comments and they went ahead
and certified the vote in august
canvassers found 72
of detroit's absentee voting precincts
didn't match the number of
ballots cast the imbalances between
august and november are not an exact
comparison since august canvassing was
based on results from 503 precincts
november's canvassing was based on 134
counting boards the same situation in
august earlier imbalances in 2016 those
were not enough to keep the same board
from certifying the results in
this year's primary and november 2016.
the board's votes came after the
absentee ballot poll books
at 70 of detroit's 134 absentee counting
boards were found to be out of balance
without explanation the mismatch varied
anywhere
from more from one to more than four
votes right so the number of absentee
ballots that were actually cast were not
the numbers that were actually taken
down
in the logs and those discrepancies were
like one two four votes in 134
absentee counting boards again that
shifts hundreds of votes it doesn't
shift thousands of votes let alone tens
of thousands with 150 000 votes the
trump
is in deficit so there should be a full
scale again all
claims of voter irregularities and voter
fraud should be fully investigated
certifying a vote saying that the vote
is not based
largely in on voter fraud or voter
irregularity
is appropriate so long as you're also
calling for an audit at the time
okay meanwhile the wall street journal
writing about the the
rage about dominion voting right a lot
of talk about dominion voting
the suggestion is that dominion voting
is the software
system that is used in some 28 states
including a bevy of republican states
texas doesn't use dominion but there are
a bunch of red states that do use
dominion
according to the wall street journal it
seems to have launched the theory that
dominion voting screwed around with the
vote was an earlier misreport
of enter in antrim county michigan in
2016 trump won 62 percent of its 13
600 ballots eyebrows rose this year when
initial tally showed biden up by 3
000 in reality trump won 61 percent of
andrum county
the unofficial reporting was wrong the
underlying votes were counted correctly
officials later explained that in
october the county had to tweak the
ballot information for two local races
tabulated machines in the affected areas
were updated but some others weren't on
election day the differing data didn't
line up right after being merged the
printouts from the tabulators did show
accurate totals
in any case the michigan secretary of
state's office said the error would have
been identified during that county
canvas when democrats and republicans
review the printed totals tape from each
tabulator
then there was another problem with the
dominion module in gwinnett county
georgia apparently
officials had trouble with a dominion
module for adjudicating absentee ballots
if the voter put a check mark in the
circle instead of filling it in
some adjudicated ballots said the counts
were displayed as in progress but would
not move over to be accepted
the county ended up re-adjudicating some
votes until november 5th
which is basically they it looks like
they fixed the problem
a couple of counties in georgia had
trouble with electronic poll books but
that would not
really affect vote totals it would
affect wait times at precincts
and then of course there's footage from
a house hearing a few years ago where a
princeton computer science professor
named dandruppel
said voting machines could theoretically
be hacked
but just because a system is vulnerable
does not mean that it actually
was hacked now here's something to
remember about dominion okay there's
been a lot of talk about dominion and
its ties we'll get to that in one second
dominion makes hundreds of millions of
dollars a year by selling its voting
systems
if they were that vulnerable to hack if
those dominion voting systems were in
fact
that easy to be gamed to the effect that
millions of votes were tabulated the
wrong way
not only is that company bankrupt it is
suited into the ground and everybody
goes to jail i mean especially if there
is fraud involved
people are going to jail right so the
incentives
don't really align to be in these the
voting the voting system business
and then create a voting system that can
be easily rigged
by somebody from the outside especially
when you sell these things all over the
world particularly in western
democracies
okay so if there are problems with dem
again full investigation full evidence
possibility of fraud is not the same
thing as fraud
just as what i've said the same exact
thing i'm being perfectly consistent
here i said the same exact thing when a
white officer shoots a
black suspect the possibility of racism
is there
does that mean that it's an actual
racist incident no i need actual
evidence
the thing that you say happened happened
the same thing is true here we'll get to
more
on dominion in just one second because i
think it's important that we all have
the proper up-to-date information so
that we can tell what is true
and what is not and where there are real
suspicions and where the suspicions are
overblown
and so that we can actually accurately
make our vote counts better and we can
ensure that voter fraud and voter
regularity did not decide this election
i understand
people being really upset about the
outcome and i understand people being
really suspicious
of the outcome of the election i
understand that a lot of people went to
sleep on tuesday night and trump was in
the lead in all these days they woke up
the next morning and all of a sudden
trump's way behind
and people go what the hell just
happened why were you pausing the
machines in the middle of the night like
what exactly was going i understand the
suspicion
suspicion is worthwhile unjustified
based on lack of evidence that's a
different ques so we need more evidence
more evidence right again i want to get
sidney powell on the program so she can
explain exactly what releasing the
kraken will look like here i think it's
really really important that we have all
the information possible
because again election integrity really
really does matter we'll get to more of
this in
just one second first let's talk about
something incredible a meaningful gift
out in your garage you have a bunch of
old photos that are falling apart you
have a bunch of old films
that are molds wearing you have a bunch
of old vhs tapes you're never going to
watch again why not get all of that
transferred over
to digital right put it on a thumb drive
put it on a tv now you can access all of
it i just did this for my parents it is
absolutely awesome they had a bunch of
old film reels of
my great great-grandparents and they'd
never been able to see those before
we took them we sent them into legacy
box legacy box digitized all of them and
sent it back to us and now we can access
our family memories it's pretty
incredible
with legacy box you can reclaim all the
priceless footage you have not been able
to see in years
their service could not be simpler you
use their kits to safely send the
moments you want preserved
their team then creates a digital
archive by hand
you receive your new copies stored on
the cloud a thumb drive or dvd along
with the original media you sent them
with their tracking system you can
monitor every step of the process so you
always know your originals are being
taken care of
over the past 10 years legacy box has
helped over 1 million families restore
and protect their most cherished
memories and right now they're offering
off you can have everything preserved at
once for a fraction of the price go to
legacybox.com
shapiro to take advantage of this
limited time offer and get 50
off you shouldn't wait to digitize all
those amazing memories
every day that goes by something bad
could happen to them out in your garage
plus
you're missing a day where you can share
that stuff with friends and family
take advantage of this exclusive offer
use the kit now send it in whenever
you're ready
go to legacybox.com shapiro say 50 while
supplies last it's one of the best
things i've done for my parents go check
them out
right now legacybox.com for the special
offer
okay so back to the talk about dominion
there's been talk about dominion and its
connections to democrats
the company in 2014 according to the
wall street journal did agree to donate
voting machines to emerging and
post-conflict democracies via clinton
foundation initiative
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
obviously they were sending faulty
voting machines that could be gained by
the clinton foundation
the company says it has no ownership
relationships with any member of the
pelosi family the feinstein family or
the clinton
global initiative there's also talk that
dominion has ties with smartmatic
a company that supplied voting systems
in venezuela where the ruling regime
manipulates elections both of the
companies openly deny this smartmatic
says quote it has never provided
dominion voting systems with any
software
hardware or other technology dominion
says they quote do not collaborate in
any way and have no affiliate
relationships or financial ties
in 2009 dominion says smartmatic quote
licensed dominion machines for use in
philippines but the contract ended
in a lawsuit this does not mean they're
not problems with dominion it does mean
you're going to have to do better than
simply saying
that dominion voting machines are
suspicious because of
ownership structure or they are
suspicious because we are
concerned that people have said there's
possibility of again possibility of
fraud is very real
it means that maybe we shouldn't be
using these voting systems in the future
if you are deeply worried those
possibilities could manifest
but just as democrats in 2004 were
saying that bolt voting machines were
hacked
and it turns out that was not the case
if you're actually going to show
that something bad happened here you
have to show that the bad thing happened
not that the possibility of the bad
thing happened particularly if you're
talking
about not certifying votes or if you're
talking about throwing this thing
to legislatures to select electors or
something like that you got to actually
show evidence that the election ought to
be i mean these are major things we're
talking about right if you're talking
about
overturning an actual election then what
you have to talk about
is are the allegations
backed by evidence sufficient to merit
that response right that is always the
legal question
it would be the legal question if
democrats were doing this to republicans
obviously okay so all of this culminated
yesterday
in the president firing uh the the cyber
security
chief uh over at the department of
homeland security
uh so he he ousted kris krabs according
to usa today the department of homeland
security cyber chief who presided over
an elaborate
election security effort guarding
against foreign interference and fraud
was ousted by president trump on tuesday
as part of a continuing post-election
purge of top national security officials
trump announced the dismissal in two
tweets on tuesday night twitter flagged
both tweets with labels saying this
claim about election fraud is disputed
who cares what twitter says i mean
honestly like twitter
by the way twitter is so full of crap
seriously twitter is super duper full of
crap
then the reason i say this my business
partner jeremy boring decided to perform
an experiment yesterday on twitter
he tweeted out stacey abrams is the
legitimate governor of georgia she only
lost because of voter fraud and voter
suppression
okay that is absolutely untrue she is
not the legitimate governor of georgia
she did not lose because of voter fraud
and voter suppression it was not flagged
by twitter
right and it is all when it says this
claim about election fraud is disputed
right this is the kind of warning that
twitter's been putting
on people's messages particularly trumps
it just doesn't apply if a democrat does
it so twitter is full of crap but that's
a different story we'll get to the
full of crappiness of twitter and
facebook in just one second
first the dismissal of christopher krebs
according to usa today director of dhs's
cyber security and infrastructure
security agency
follows the agency's declaration that
the general election was the most secure
in u.s history
president trump disagreed and president
trump tweeted out the recent statement
by kris krebs and the security of the
2020 election was highly inaccurate
and that there were massive
improprieties and fraud including dead
people voting poll watchers not allowed
into polling locations glitches in the
voting machines
which changed excuse me which changed
votes from trump to biden late voting
and many more
therefore effective immediately kris
krebs has been terminated as director of
the cyber security and infrastructure
security agency
so it's not that trump thinks that that
krebs did a bad job protecting the
election he doesn't like that krebs said
that he did a good job
in protecting the election because
obviously trump is saying i still have
lawsuits outstanding
and he's saying i still have you know
claims that i'm making currently in
court and you are undercutting
those claims and those claims are still
under dispute
now the the cyber security agency that
krebs is heading up the cyber security
and infrastructure security agency saisa
they put out a statement earlier this
week saying there's no evidence that any
voting system deleted or lost votes
changed votes or was in any way
compromised
all the states with close results in the
2020 presidential race have paper
records of each vote allowing the
ability to go back and count each ballot
if necessary this is an added benefit
for security and resilience this process
allows for the identification and
correction of any mistakes
or errors and then krebs tweeted out
after trump fired him
honored to serve we did it right defend
today secure it tomorrow
krebs i mean literally his job was to
defend the election security system so
you would imagine he would defend his
own job
right he would defend what kind of a job
like does that mean he's right
um i mean i don't know if he's right i i
until there is further evidence you have
to assume that the election was not
victimized by millions and millions of
fraudulent votes or
hacked voting machines or something like
that but of course he's going to defend
what he did right i mean he was the head
of the dhs's
you know cyber security agency he
tweeted out
on allegations that election systems
were manipulated 59 election security
experts all agree
in every case of which we are aware
these claims either have been
unsubstantiated or are technically
incoherent krebs is expecting to be
fired as recently as last week according
to politico
this prompted a wave of criticism from
both sides of the aisle
uh with obviously the usual democrats
criticizing all of this
um but also some of the republicans
criticizing this as well
now krebs was a trump hire right krebs
did not serve
in the in democratic administration he
was not a holdover from the obama era
krebs joined dhs in march 2017 he served
as senior advisor on cyber security and
infrastructure protection
he was tasked with safeguarding national
cyber networks along with maintaining
the country's
essential operations in the face of
increasing attempts by foreign
adversaries to disrupt the government
the nation's vulnerability was made
clear in 2016
when it's when quote unquote russia
sought to undermine the general election
according to usa today so we're still
going to go with the myth that russia
undermined
the general election in 2016 in some
significant way um
but we have to be assured that this
election is perfectly clean
and wondrous now should trump be firing
people for saying that sort of stuff
presumably not i mean the guy is
defending the job that he did obviously
does that mean that the election is pure
and clean
we don't know yet again all of the
evidence still has to be presented so
present the evidence guys now is the
time less
legal wrangling and legal maneuvering
less kind of open allegations of the
possibility
and now we need the evidence you're
talking about hundreds of millions of
people
you're talking about 150 million people
voted in this last election
you're talking about millions of people
voting in pennsylvania and arizona and
georgia
and michigan and if you're going to
overturn the results in these particular
states you need to actually show the
evidence now
right no more of the pitching this stuff
on national tv more of the evidence
showing
that that doesn't seem like a big ask in
fact it seems like a pretty good thing
for the country for every
everybody to put their cards on the
table at this particular point in time
and none of that is to suggest of course
that there's not voter fraud or voter
regularities i've said 1 000 times there
absolutely is but it has to be up to
a certain level of effectiveness in
order for it to affect the outcome
of elections that have huge numbers of
people voting again the deficit in
pennsylvania right now is 70 000.
okay we can always make the elections
cleaner and we should full audits should
be available
of all of these states we should go
through every ballot tabulated we should
make sure that everybody who is legally
voted is counted and everybody who
legally voted
is not counted right that's all we
should all be on the same page about all
of this
but if you're talking about we need to
overturn the results of an entire
election
in a particular state or disenfranchise
the voters of michigan or pennsylvania
or nevada or arizona
or georgia we need to see the actual
evidence now is the time now is the time
so bring the evidence forth
sunlight is the best disinfectant more
sunlight more sunlight okay so we'll get
to
more of this in just one second facebook
and twitter
we're on the hill again and the
democratic agenda here is absolutely
clear the democratic agenda
is to ensure that nobody they disagree
with is ever allowed to talk again
we'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about the fact that
there are a lot of people out there who
are seeking to put malware on your
computer ransomware right things that
are designed to make your life miserable
and steal your data
or hold up your data so that you pay
them it really is ugly stuff if you've
ever been hit by malware it can
absolutely ruin your life
pcmatic it's a next-generation
anti-virus designed to stop modern
threats like ransomware
independent testing from av test just
named pcmatic as a top performer in the
cyber security industry
giving it the best performance award for
2019. only pcmatic has american research
development and support
pcmatic's competition is foreign made
often in countries where malware
originates
pcmatic blocks annoying and malicious
ads for hassle-free web browsing and
makes your computer faster and more
reliable even after years of use
pcmatic protects windows computers
including xp vista windows 7 8 and 10
windows servers max macbooks and android
phones and tablets pcmatic is just 50
bucks for five devices for one year
the full 30 day money back guarantee if
you act now pcmatic has offered my
listeners a free month of security
protection
with the purchase of an annual license
again you're making a big mistake if
you're not protecting yourself from
malware or ransomware or stuff like i
mean it really is
horrifying stuff when it hits you make
sure you're protected go access this
offer at pcmatic.com
ben again to get world-class security
that keeps your computer running great
go to pcmatic.com
okay we're gonna get to more of the news
in just
one second including the democrats
grilling
facebook and twitter on the hill
republicans want anthem too
first if you're not disgusted by the
establishment media you should be and
the simple fact of the matter is that
the
the media threw the election to joe
biden if the media had not been out
there stumping every day against donald
trump if the media had not spent
the last several years undermining trump
and suggesting that joe biden was clean
as the driven snow and not reporting on
any of joe biden's improprieties
then biden would have lost that election
just because the media declared a
narrative to be true does not actually
mean that it is true it just means they
are pushing a narrative so
now it is time for you to fight back
what is the best way for you to fight
back against the mainstream
establishment media narrative to replace
them okay you need to cut your cable
right now
you need to go and subscribe to daily
wire our goal is to replace the media
and provide you
with narratives that are true to provide
you with facts
that happen to be true and not colored
by the leftist view of the universe
we have huge plans to replace the media
over the next four years it starts today
candace owens the new york times
best-selling author and founder of the
blexit foundation is joining the daily
wire
she'll be launching a brand new show
with us earlier next year we couldn't be
more excited about it we're also
launching
an entertainment channel a new
investigative journalism team building
partnerships with like-minded content
creators like prageru
whose entire show library will be
available to daily wire members by the
end of the year
we're going after the legacy media we're
going to do it by building a huge
membership base of supporters
like you right now just to show you
we're serious we're offering 25
off all memberships with code election
over at dailywire.com
subscribe members get our articles ad
free access to all of our live broadcast
and show library the full three hours of
the ben shapiro show
exclusive readers past content available
only to our daily wire members if you're
considering an all-access membership you
get to join us on all access live every
night for live stream discussions with
our hosts
and an amazing online community you also
get not one but two
leftist tears tumblers with your
membership as well as early sometimes
exclusive access to new daily wire
products so remember that's 25
off all memberships with code election
over at dailywire.com
subscribe replace the legacy media with
daily wire you won't regret it and
you'll be making the country a better
place just by doing it you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
alrighty so meanwhile facebook and
twitter appearing on the hill
and you can see the different agendas of
the republicans and democrats when it
comes to facebook and twitter
republicans are saying
you guys really should allow people to
speak their minds on your platforms
i mean this is what your platforms were
created for and democrats are like you
know what you should really do you
should use your massive social media
power to ensure
that no one is ever able to express
their opinion if we don't like their
opinion
it's incredibly obvious that democrats
are seeking to
enjoin conservatives from expressing
their opinion or disseminating
information
they don't like so richard blumenthal
idiot
senator from connecticut he actually
demanded that mark zuckerberg ban steve
bannon and zuckerberg's like do you have
like grounds for banning steve bannon
and and blumenthal's like i don't like
him we're not gonna like what if we just
don't let him on on the system that'd be
great democrats
see social media as a way of quashing
their opposition and they are angry
that places like facebook allow their
opposition to exist
so they've made it impossible for any
republican the media have made it
impossible for any open republican
to work at a mainstream publication and
then when you form
a different kind of publication like
daily wire and you disseminate your
information
through social media like twitter or
facebook democrats are like you know
it'd be great if we shut that down too
here's richard blumenthal trying to do
this yesterday
how many times has steve bannon allowed
the call for the murder
of government officials before facebook
suspends his account senator
as you say the content in question did
violate our policies and we took it down
will you commit to taking down that
account steve bannon's account
senator no it's that that's not what our
policies would suggest that we should do
again zuckerberg at least is being
consistent there you can see how he's
getting brow beaten
by members of the democratic party which
is the great irony here what you are
seeing
from facebook's internals well what
you're seeing from from the leaked
reports about what's going on inside
facebook
is that facebook is being bullied by the
left to comply with the left
in the assumption that people on the
right are going to be in favor of free
speech and free enterprise and defend
them even as they quash speech from the
right
it ain't gonna happen it ain't gonna
happen anyway chris coons from delaware
right he does the same thing
he says i want facebook and i want
twitter to censor climate denialism
he says can you guys please you know
shut down anybody's ability
to speak about their doubts about
climate change solutions proposed by the
left
the democrats are all in favor of
censorship you think these are your free
speech protectors good luck
you do mr dorsey have um policies
against
uh deep fakes or manipulated media
against covet 19 misinformation against
things that violate civic integrity but
you don't have a standalone
climate change misinformation policy i'd
urge you to reconsider that because
helping uh to disseminate climate
denialism in my view
um further facilitates and accelerates
one of the greatest existential threats
to our world
okay i mean this is crazy so he's saying
that if you don't agree with my
perspective on climate change i want
woke rasputin over here jack dorsey
to actually stop that information from
being disseminated the democrats are
very clear in what they want here
the democrats are very clear they want a
single party system a single party
dominating
your methods of informational
dissemination this is how they got you
abiding elected this is what they hope
to do
they hope to use social media as a
weapon to siphon off
all of the possible information they
don't like and make it and make it go
away disappear into the ether
democrats cannot be trusted with free
speech principles if they had their way
you would not be able to listen to shows
like this one and you're going to see
this weaponized
not just by social media companies
you're going to see it weaponized by
credit card companies
there will come a point here here's my
prediction there will come a point in
which credit card companies
under pressure from woke staffers and
from members of democratic congress
decide that they are simply not going to
allow you to charge
on your credit card anything they don't
like so if you decide that you're going
to subscribe to daily wire there will
come a point
where your credit card company says you
can't because they're conservative and
we don't like that
or you want to buy a gun with your
credit card a credit card company will
say nope you can't do that
you can't use your charge card for that
the predictable result of that
will be that there will be right-wing
credit cards and left-wing credit cards
the left
is so determined to wish everybody they
don't like out into the cornfield all
they're gonna do is create entire new
right-wing ecosystems that's all that's
going to happen there will be two
parallel systems
you'll only be able to go to the
right-wing restaurant or the left-wing
restaurant you'll only be able to go
to the right-wing credit card or the
left-wing credit card you don't you're
only going to be able to go over to
parlor because twitter is going to ban
you right i mean
this is the way that the left wants
things to be and then they complain that
those alternative systems even exist
right they complain that parlor is even
a thing
they're whining about how so many people
are joining parlor yes it turns out when
you weaponize a social media company
against people you disagree with
those people will leave and go find an
alternative method of talking with one
another
maisie hirono the stupidest person in
the united states energy is a complete
and
utter dud intellectually and the the
senator from hawaii
she slammed facebook why because they
allowed the daily caller
fact-checking sites to be included in
their fact checkers now as i have
mentioned when it comes to social media
social media do something deeply corrupt
they outsource
all of their political predilections to
the fact checkers so what they do is
they go to politifact or snopes
or factcheck.org all left-wing sites the
washington post fact checker all
left-wing sites who very often are not
even checking facts
very often these fact checks will say
things like well sure what the
republican
was saying here was was factually true
but it packs a false
narrative and then they will use that as
a rationale for downgrading particular
news sites
so we've had this experience with for
example there's a site called newsguard
newsguard has downgraded our site not
because what we report is false
but we report things that are mistaken
sometimes just like cnn does
they've downgraded us because we are
openly an opinion site that also does
news reporting
so what they do these social media
companies they outsource to places like
newsguard to decide whether an outlet is
good or not and naturally a news guard
decides that left-wing outlets
and establishment media outlets those
are good and everybody on the right is
bad okay so they're doing the same thing
with the fact-checkers
facebook actually does allow one
quote-unquote right-wing fact checker
that'd be the daily caller maisie hirono
is like
well we shouldn't allow that there
shouldn't be any fact checkers on the
right and in fact the daily caller is a
white supremacist site which of course
the daily caller is not but maisie
hirono is a complete so here she
is
and early in 2019 facebook selected the
daily caller
another site with white nationalist ties
to be one of his third party fact
checkers and this is
that where i i'm really wondering at one
point at what point you will stop giving
in
to basics claims of anti-conservative
bias and start exercising
your control over facebook to stop
driving division and actually support
you
build community and put the world closer
together and hope
as you claim is facebook's mission it's
ridiculous so they want to make sure
that all the fact checkers are left-wing
fact checkers so that they can launder
their left-wing views through the
fact-checkers and then just say hey look
the fact-checkers say the site's bad so
we're just not going to allow
the site anymore how how ridiculous is
maisie toronto she cited media matters
to suggest that facebook and twitter are
not biased against conservatives
media matters commedia matters is a is a
political action organization started by
hillary clinton and david brock
with the explicit design of protecting
the clintons it is a
it is an organization that dedicates its
time to listening to shows like this one
clipping things out of context and then
attempting to make them trend via echo
chamber on twitter so they can go after
advertisers they're a left-wing front
group okay they've always been a
left-wing group
the attempt to use media matters is some
sort of objective news verifier when it
comes to facebook and twitter
like hey if media matters says that that
facebook and twitter aren't biased
against conservatives well then it must
be true
that's legitimately like me citing the
epic times to the idea
that left-wingers never experienced
hardship in the united states like what
are you talking about that's an overtly
partisan group it's not like to make any
bones about it here's maisie hirono
being an idiot as
she is want to do everyone who has
systematically looked at the
content of social media from
media matters to the cato institute to
former republican senator
john kyle has found absolutely no
evidence
of anti-conservative bias and data from
proud tangle show that far right content
from the likes of fox news ben shapiro
david bongino dominates the daily top 10
most engaged pages on
facebook okay well the reason that we
dominate on facebook
is because there are like three of us if
you actually look at these sites
that have the most at traffic via via
facebook
it is at least mostly establishment
media sites
right it is it is mainstream media sites
that is that is what they are right
they get a lot of their traffic from
facebook they spend millions of dollars
on facebook every month
and the the idea that that right-wingers
are not biased against on facebook i can
tell i can tell you this
you can look at the quote-unquote top 10
in terms of reach the reach on my page
has been artificially suppressed over
the last two months
okay this is perfectly clear we can see
it happening in real time
and the reason it was suppressed is
because people like mazie hirono and
kevin roose decided they were going to
yell at facebook until they suppressed
that so
the people who have not yet been
suppressed are people like dan bongino
right dan
knows that it's coming for him too which
is why he has started alternative social
media sites but this is the whole point
the whole point is that the democratic
left does not
want you to be able to consume
information that you are interested in
consuming
and the woke staffers inside these
various organizations are all for it
they're all for
the use of these social media platforms
as ways to cram down the left-wing point
of view
right this is a point that uh that ted
cruz made to jack dorsey
because dorsey has been labeling things
misinformation on voter fraud so cruz
was like um so are you an expert on
voter fraud
why is it that only some posts get
labeled misinformation on voter fraud
not others
does voter fraud exist
i i don't know for certain are you an
expert in voter fraud
no i'm not well why then is twitter
right now
putting purported warnings on
virtually any statement about voter
fraud
we're we're simply linking to a broader
conversation so that people have more
information no
no you're not you put up a page that
says quote voter fraud of any kind is
exceedingly rare in the united states
that's not linking to a broader
conversation that's taking a disputed
policy position
and you're a publisher when you're doing
that okay so ted is exactly right about
this of course senator cruz when he says
that you guys are taking a position
as i said yesterday my business partner
tweeted out something overtly false
about stacey abrams being governor of
georgia
not flagged by twitter if you said that
there's widespread voter fraud in the
united states that is flagged as false
by twitter so
twitter obviously has its own point of
view on things they're entitled to that
but let's not pretend that they are some
sort of neutral arbiter of information
meanwhile in stories that presumably the
establishment media wish that you would
not look at
there are these georgia senate races the
georgia senate races by the polling data
for whatever good it does
are virtually dead even you have jon
ossoff running against david perdue
david produced the incumbent senator
in georgia and then you have senator
kelly leffler who's appointed to that
seat
she is running against raphael warnock
now purdue did beat ossoff
in georgia he beat him by about two
percentage points he did not surpass 50
which is what you need to avoid the
runoff he did that in a in a time
when trump allegedly lost georgia by you
know 12 000 votes or so
so that was a bad performance by jon
ossoff
the the performance by rafael warnock he
went about 33 of the vote but it was a
three-way primary essentially
uh now it's kelly lefler versus warnock
the polls are saying that that thing is
close to dead even but who care like
honestly can you take the polls with any
level of seriousness at this point if
rafael warnock were to pull out that
seat in georgia it would be a shocker
the reason it would be a shocker is
because rafael warnock is a nutty
marxist
like a crazy person so in 2011 for
example
it's obvious the democrats are not
bothered about this guy rafael warnock
said in 2011 in a speech on tape that
you cannot serve both god and the
military
literally if you're in the military you
are against god which is a hell of a
thing to say
about you know the men and women of
america's military who are fighting for
our freedom and the freedom of people
like rafael warnock to be complete
jackasses
america nobody can serve god and the
military
you can't serve god and money you cannot
serve
god and mama at the same time america
choose jesus day
whom you will serve you can't serve god
and the military you can't be in the
military and be
and be a good christian also but you
know what you can do you can back
abortion to be a great christian so you
can't be in the military and be a good
christian but according to rafael
warnock
abortion is consistent with his
christian views which suggests to me
that uh this guy really
let's just say he's untraditional in his
view of christianity
i believe that healthcare is a human
right
and i believe that it is something that
the richest nation in the world provides
for its citizens
and for me reproductive justice is
consistent with my commitment to that
i believe unequivocally in a woman's
right to choose
and that the decision uh it's something
that we
we don't want government engaged in i've
been focused on women's health women's
choice and reductive justice
uh that is consistent with my view of
uh as a christian minister so here's
what we know about rafael warnock
he's hot on marx he kind of likes castro
he's very much in favor of abortion he's
very much against the us military
and he calls all of this christian
excellent vetting democratic senatorial
campaign committee
we'll see how that goes for you it's a
bold move cotton we'll see how it goes
for them
over in georgia okay meanwhile we have
some good news and we have some bad news
on
covet 19. so here is some good news
there is actual good news coming so
pfizer now says their vaccine is 95
effective in their final data they are
going to seek authorization from the fba
fda emergency authorization as of like
right now
according to the wall street journal an
experimental cova 19 vaccine from pfizer
and bio entec
was 95 effective in final results from a
pivotal study and showing signs of being
safe
key pieces of data as the companies
prepare to ask health regulates
health regulators to authorize use
pfizer plans to seek authorization for
that vaccine within days the company
said wednesday
leaving the shot on track to go into
distribution by the end of the year if
health regulators permit
now it's true that tens of millions of
people won't be able to get the doses
but
tens of millions of people may not need
the doses if you start with the most
vulnerable
my kids don't need doses of the vaccine
i don't need a dose of the vaccine
right the death rates on people who are
under the age of 70
are pretty scanty particularly if you
have no pre-existing conditions it's
something like five and one thousand are
the death rates on people who are under
the age of 70 in the united states and
that includes people with pre-existing
conditions so if you're in good health
and you're 30
you probably don't need the vaccine
right away in order for everybody to
sort of start getting back to
normal life the 95 effectiveness rate
puts the shot's performance on power
with shingles and measles which is
really damned effective it's also
consistent with the vaccine showing in a
peak last week and how it did
in an analysis of the first 94 subjects
to fall sick
researchers have not yet found any
serious safety issues the vaccine
appears to be well tolerated following a
review
from 8 000 study subjects a severe side
effect was fatigue that was reported by
about four percent of the subjects
about two percent of subjects reported
headaches but that's not like gm bar
syndrome or something
the company said they have collected two
months of safety data on about 19 000
study subjects requested by the fda
they're still reviewing all of those
results earlier
moderna reported a similarly strong
preliminary result for its shot
which the biotech said was 94.5
effective
in an early look studies show that a lot
of people are hesitant to get the shots
the evidence suggests that that
hesitancy is uh probably
not worthwhile at this point a committee
of independent health experts has
analyzed the data
from the trial and reported the results
to pfizer and bio and tech the companies
released the data by press release
and they plan to publish the results in
more detail later in a peer-reviewed
medical journal
the fda is expected to take some time to
consider the request for permission to
distribute the vaccine
that will require a review by an outside
committee of vaccine experts the fda
plans to expedite the review
obviously during the pandemic the fda
has authorized emergency use
for several drugs including rem desevier
and recently a coveted 19 antibody drug
from
eli lilly and company upon authorization
pfizer plans to produce up to 50 million
doses by the end of the year about half
of which would be destined for the
united states
the supplies would be enough to
inoculate about 12.5 million americans
because each person needs to take two
doses
three weeks apart now
again that's a great start i mean if you
start with people who are the most
vulnerable people in nursing homes
people with
significant pre-existing conditions
there are tens of millions of those
people
but if you start with healthcare workers
for example and you start with the
people who are
most likely to die namely people who are
above the age of 70 with pre-existing
conditions
well you're going to bring down those
death rates pretty significantly and
pretty quickly so that is excellent
excellent news and more excellent news
it turns out immunity to coronavirus
could last for a year according to
apoorva mandeville reporting from the
new york times
years maybe even decades immunity might
last eight months after infection most
people who have recovered still have
enough immune cells to fend off the
virus and prevent illness according to
new data a slow rate of decline in the
short term suggests that these cells may
persist in the body for a very very long
time to come
the research published online has not
been peer reviewed or published in a
scientific journal it is the most
comprehensive and long-ranging study of
immune memory to the chromovirus to date
now this does show how irresponsible the
media are remember the media
found like one case all over the world
of a guy who was reinfected with covet
and i was like well
who knows how long immunity is going to
last remember when president trump said
he was immune from the virus now that
he'd had it
everybody in the media were like how
dare he say that we don't know that for
sure
no we kind of knew it then and we
certainly know it now so can we stop
with all this crap where you find
some wild case of a guy being reinfected
out of the millions of people
tens of millions of people who've been
infected by this thing and instead why
not look at the actual stats
it's the same sort of stuff you hear
about long-lasting symptoms
from covid i'm sure that that does
happen i know people tap into
does that mean that like what percentage
of people should you be deeply worried
about that
until we see percentages this means
nothing again evidence evidence evidence
a study published last week found that
people who have recovered from covenant
have powerful and protective killer
immune cells even when antibodies are
not detectable
according to bhattacharya immunologist
at the university of arizona the studies
are all by and large painting the same
picture once you get past those first
few critical weeks
the rest of the response looks pretty
conventional akiko awasaki immunologist
at yale said she was not surprised the
body mounts a long-lasting response
because that's what's supposed to happen
still she says that is very exciting
news and it is exciting news
right that is that is very very good
stuff obviously
so that is good news more good news the
fda has now authorized the first at-home
coronavirus test
they give an emergency green light to
the first rapid covet test that can run
from start to finish at home
the test was developed by lucira health
it requires a prescription from a
healthcare provider
people under 14 can't perform the test
on themselves but with a relatively
simple nasal swab the test can return
results in about half an hour it is
projected by the company to cost 50
bucks or less
according to the product's website
clinicians can also run the tests on
their patients including kids under the
age of 14
potentially delivering answers during a
single visit to a care center or
pharmacy
instead of having this routine where you
have to take the sample and then wait
for hours to get the result right all of
this means that we are going to be
bringing down
the rates of transmission it means that
we're going to be bringing down the
rates of death because if you can
identify this stuff earlier you can
treat it better
all of this is really really good news
right so we should be very very happy
about all of this
meanwhile it's hilarious to note that
the media have finally noticed that it's
a bad thing that democrats have been
holding up kovade
so remember that time when nancy pelosi
for months held up a coveted relief
package
because she wanted to hurt president
trump at the ballot box remember that
and trump was like i want to make a deal
and nancy pelosi is like i don't want to
make a deal and the media kept
completely silent because they run at
the behest of nancy pelosi well now the
election's over and they're saying to
nancy pelosi you know what you should do
probably make a covered relief deal
once again showing that our ridiculous
media are indeed ridiculous and awful
so according to the washington post this
is the editorial board congress's
stimulus impasse must end
even if it means democrats accepting a
smaller deal you know when you could
have written this
if you were actually honest a month ago
a month ago
by the way i'm not going to pretend that
nancy pelosi's in transitions
has not contributed to her almost losing
the house of representatives
there are another two republican there
are another two seats that could flip
democrats or republican over the course
of the next 48 hours
which means the republicans could pick
up to 14 seats in the house
which virtually no one had predicted now
the editorial board at the washington
post is like you know would have been
great if nancy pelosi had signed a
covert relief deal because people are
suffering
according to the washington post
editorial board
when negotiations between pelosi and the
trump administration broke off before
the november third election
the latter had upped its offer to 1.9
trillion dollars but the speaker
objected the proposal lacked details
such as a plan for containing the virus
and in any case was smaller than the 2.2
trillion dollars
the house passed in early october
meanwhile trump was sending mixed
signals while senate majority leader
mitch mcconnell was refusing to accept
anything more than 500 billion
if pelosi's strategy was to hold out
until a democratic sweep increased her
leverage it didn't quite work out
democrats retain the house by a narrow
majority and control of the senate
awaits two georgia runoffs the precise
distribution of clout in washington is
anyone's guess but the nation needs
especially those of the working poor and
the unemployed are beyond question
priorities for a new package include
extending eviction limits and special
unemployment benefits for gig workers
another round of forgivable no interest
loans to small businesses and aids
state and local governments possibly at
least some elements may be attached to a
spending bill that congress must pass by
december 11th
to avoid a partial government shutdown
so
hilariously the media have now decided
you know what would be great to pass
this covered relief bill notice they
didn't put any pressure on nancy pelosi
to do that for literally months
before before the election because
they're a bunch of partisan hats who
essentially work for the democratic
party
at this point by the way quick note on
the uh joe biden
and his staffing up so his selected
white house staff thus far
is likely to disappoint progressives if
you think there's going to be an easy
period for the democrats even if joe
biden ends up
taking the inaugural oath which god
forbid even if that
ends up happening joe biden hears his
staff
according to ken vogel writing for the
new york times venture capital executive
ronald mclean former pharmaceutical and
insurance lobbyist steve verschetti
top democratic recipients big oil money
cedric richmond and a co-founder of a
firm
that represents pharma and private
equity joe malley-dixon so uh that's
great
uh just gonna point out here that joe
biden
is the establishment's idea of an
establishment democrat
that is what he is and he's going to be
at war with his own progressive wing and
so we very much
look forward to that even if this
election this presidential election
ends up going the wrong way okay we'll
be back here later today with two
additional hours of content otherwise
we'll see you here tomorrow i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are nick sheehan and
rebecca doyle
the show is edited by adam scievent
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by nico geneva the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
cnn admits that their hacks gavin newsom
and jack dorsey
apologize and the gop cleans up in
contested house elections check it out
on the michael knowles show
[Music]